if you are a fanatic purist you prohibit
yourself to enjoy but then all of a
sudden you discover yourself enjoying
the very rituals of prohibition
[Music]
let me begin years ago I was reading a
text about how the Nazis tortured
prisoners in the concentration camps it
affected me quite dramatically when I
found that they used industrially made
testicle crashes like to crack nuts they
made them industrially to torture
prisoners in concentration camps now
I did something I didn't want to be
caught lying again so I simply went to
Google or whatever and put a
testicle Crusher or ball crasher to get
the data I was extremely surprised when
I got an answer immediately but not
about the Nazis I got a couple of
websites advertising where they say pick
your poison for pleasure from this ball
torture group then you have stainless
steel ball Crusher stainless ball clamp
torture device brutal Vice torture
toy and so on and so on I think that
this passage from the ball crasher used
to torture prisoners in Nazi
contentation camps to the ball cluster
that you can buy they're very nicely
done even with some small diamonds for
for 500 pounds
this will undoubtedly be celebrated as a
sign of historical progress the same
progress which brings us classic works
of art purified of the content they that
may hurt somebody so that's where we are
you shouldn't use a wrong word like he
or she when it should be day but you get
or the pain
that you want from a ball Crusher the
question that bothers me today is
uh I'm not against this I think that
this ball crashing machines and so on
are not a pathological phenomenon that
they indicate
something that is imminent to our
sexuality so why does the permissive
stance towards sexual pleasures entail
impotence and frigidity why when
pleasure is enjoined by a superego
figure are we deprived of it why in
these conditions the only way is to
enjoy through pain I'm raising here of
course the old Freudian question why do
we enjoy oppression itself that is to
say power edifice asserts its hold over
us not simply by oppression or
repression they are not the same but
which are sustained by a fear of
punishment power asserts Itself by
bribing us for our obedience and
enforced renunciations what we get get
in exchange for our obedience and
renunciation is a perverted pleasure in
renunciation in itself
in loss itself here comes a very nice
ambiguity of lacon's term for Surplus
enjoyment blue if you know minimally
friend you know that blue the can mean a
surplus
but it can also mean negative no longer
enjoyment so uh
Lacon
formulated this term
with reference of course to Marx Merv
Surplus value
Lacon added Surplus
enjoyment and Freud already doesn't have
a term but called this Luft Gavin a gain
of pleasure which does not designate a
simple stepping up of pleasure more
pleasure but the additional pleasure
provided by the very formal detours in
the subject effort to attain
pleasure another figure of this Luft
Gavin is the reversal that characterizes
hysteria
renutation to pleasure reverts into
pleasure of renunciation repression of
Desire reverts into desire for
repression and I think I'm here although
we are enemies theoretically but
personally normal relations here I agree
with her I refer her to Judith Butler
where he develops in one of her texts
about psychoanalysis very nicely this
point of how yes enjoyment is impossible
direct pure enjoyment but at the same
time you cannot get rid of enjoyment for
example if you are a fanatic purist you
prohibit yourself to enjoy but then all
of a sudden you discover yourself
enjoying the very rituals of prohibition
and lacon's point is that there is no
zero level pure enjoyment non-oppressed
enjoyment which would then be repressed
and so on no enjoyment is such
uh uh an excess this brings me now to uh
this Gables uh Gables speak again
I think that this uh
speak as already said stands for Pure
Sublime in the sense of his messages you
think you've already seen enough
suffering no way you will suffer
immediately more and the result is a
quite open obscene enjoyment now ah now
comes my trick maybe you will say but
wait a minute wasn't this all staked my
point it doesn't matter
the way ideology works today and already
in the Nazi time is that the most
dangerous false distance is when you
tell yourself oh but I'm not taking it
seriously no it is serious and you are
not aware how serious it is or Freud has
a very nice formula for this when he
says we are not only more immoral than
we think our either
yes is also more moral than we think so
again where is here the Surplus
enjoyment in global City speech it is
produced by the very renunciations he
imposes on the people
a look at his distorted face when he
shouts his challenges to the public his
enjoyment at its purest
and now I come to the pessimist said
conclusions is in killing the truth the
Surplus is produced by the very fact
that brutal murder is presented as the
highest Duty so that while I enjoy I can
tell myself that I'm doing my duty I'm
improvised a little bit on this already
yesterday how for me the most
depressing horrible thing is that Earth
and I gave yesterday two examples not
only the Nazis but also in a different
way I don't confuse them the Stalin is
Terror in
gulak you know the really depressive
thing is that like we all have some
sense of common decency but to
present you to you as the highest
ethical challenge that you are ready to
sacrifice your common decency for the
good of the nation for the high cost and
so on and so on for example Heinrich
Himmler the really bad guy the chief of
ss and so on he
put this at its purest in his message to
uh
SS officers killing the Jews he said
when you are confronted with the Jewish
lady and her small son both sides are
already covered by Blood crying totally
helpless there comes the greatest
ethical Temptation that if you feel
sympathy for them the highest ethical
stance is to ignore this common decency
and to do it and even himner comes close
to saying this that every idiot can be
seduced like he did it here
by giving his life for his country and
him no the highest ethical Act is to
sell yours sell your soul to the devil
to do the most horrible things as the
highest ethical Duty and I found again
repeating myself from yesterday in some
stalinist notes in the early 30s when
they did
the collectivization it was the same
when they were preparing
a people to go to The Villages and First
Farmers into collectivization they said
you will do the most horrible things you
will have to ignore small Starving
Children families but he says there is
the Temptation they call this temptation
of course Bourgeois sentimentalism
liberalism and so on that and now you
will say but this is an exaggeration no
I don't have time now to go into
this in detail but uh I found traces of
this today clearly in also in Russian
but especially American ultright
Alternative rights
the scientist Trump and all of them are
mostly giving the same message they say
Trump openly says a couple of months ago
that our sense of justice that he won
really the elections and so on allows us
to ignore even the Constitution
you see and here things get but I will
not go into it by my next book if you're
literally very sad for example so many
friends of mine were depressed when you
remember two years ago when was it
yesterday after the at the uh when the
the trumpian crowd entered Congress
occupies it you know that my many of my
Lefty friends were crying they said my
God we should have been doing he the
people and this is the same sad thing
today even the leninist violent upheaval
topic is taken over by the Earth by the
alt right so that this liberal left did
you notice how all they can do is they
call for police like all my leftist
liberal friends were saying where was
the National Guard there saying where
was the police and so on and so on and
not to mention guys really disgusting
like Steve Bannon they may be most
intelligent
theorist ideologist of trump trumpism he
proclaimed himself openly a leninist he
says I'm the only serious leninist today
because like for learning my task is to
destroy the state
so that the people take it over now I
know what you will say this is only a
mask of the privileged big capital and
so on but my point is it doesn't matter
this engrenders an incredible Surplus
enjoyment
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas